hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
Teen Wolf taught us a whole new way to
create a werewolf
seriously raise your hand if you just
got a little bit hungry after the
episode don't worry I won't judge
they were like at least four new plot
lines that got started so let's just
chop right in hello to all the new
people if you're just finding me for the
first time I'm doing weekly Teen Wolf
videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything I also included a playlist in
the description in case you want to
travel down the youtubes Teen Wolf
rabbit hole here are details on the
comic-con panel so Teen Wolf is gonna be
a Comic Con on Thursday July 24th the
panel is at 3:30 p.m. and they're
basically bringing Jeff Davis the
creator Tyler Posey Dylan O'Brien Tyler
hoechlin
Holland Roden Shelley Hennig and Dylan
Sprayberry the new Liam character
they're also gonna debut the trailer for
the second half of the season so I'll be
sure to do a full breakdown of that and
if I don't get a video at that weekend
I'll include it in my Monday video for
the episode that week so let's get to
Episode three what I'm gonna do is my
top five moments and then I'll do my
review careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet all
wait just a sec okay here we go
number five Kate takes Derek's true
nature we finally get an answer to
Derek's eye color I actually thought it
was some conceit of the de-aging spell
but it sounds like Kate did that to him
to both get inside the vault and to take
his true nature the only reason that
comes to mind is that she needs it to
power some other weird ritual whenever
they said true nature I actually thought
more about identity like she took
Derek's identity so now that Derek does
not have that he won't be able to
complete some sort of important task
later this season until he gets that
back did you see the way he was acting -
I actually thought it was young Derek
for a second in old Derek's body he
seemed like he was staring at himself a
lot like he didn't know himself I have
to give Tyler hoechlin props for being
able to play a different version of
Derek without it seeming cheesy let me
know what you think we should call this
version of Derek like we can call
regular Derek Derek Prime and this Derek
like shadow Derek or something like that
it does seem like he's operating at a
fraction of his normal capacity like
he's in panic mode right now
number 4 Lydia finds the meat locker if
you were confused don't feel bad it took
me till the end reveal of Sean being a
Wendigo
for me to understand the meat locker the
mute played by Joseph gap from Game of
Thrones was
his family because they were
supernatural it seemed like he might
have done something funky to him in the
bathroom but really the mute is
attacking supernatural families in
beacon hills that's part of the Deadpool
kill list and the benefactor the next
episode episode four is actually called
the benefactor so presumably we're gonna
find out what's going on with him but
when Lydia found the meat locker she was
finding Sean's family's refrigerator
basically Wendigos are from Algonquin
mythology they're basically cannibal
monsters so that's why those were human
bodies in that meat locker the family
just kept them on ice like you keep
steaks on ice pretty gross huh
so that's why at the end whatever he
said I'm so hungry he wasn't on drugs or
anything he just hadn't fed on human
flesh in a long time do not ask what is
in his Gatorade bottle the other really
important thing that was happening here
I felt like was Lydia forming a
connection with deputy Parrish
he seemed amazingly sanguine about her
supernatural banshee status even though
I don't think that he knows she's a
banshee she still doesn't understand how
her power works either so they basically
just treated it like a weird WTF skill
that she has I feel like this is gonna
end up turning into more of like a
Mulder or Scully relationship where she
just starts being more proactive about
seeking out murders her power draws her
to people who are near death or who have
just died so she's got like a super
radar for death I'm really interested to
see her learn how to use this ability a
little bit more and see if there's any
other aspects to it they just haven't
manifested yet but number four
Malia versus math I love the way the
show bounces between adorable and crazy
murder so fast last week I said Malia
was my favorite character so far this
year I think lacrosse Kira might give
her a run for her money but the look on
her face whenever she walked into math
class was priceless
I feel like the reaction phases that
some of the cast members make are what
they're really paid for like it's a rare
ability to be able to make amazing faces
like that on command all day long it was
just like there was a giant middle
finger drawn on that chalkboard it's
just a twist of the challenges that each
of the characters are facing this season
like Malia is more afraid of math than
she is a Berserker squishing them like
grapes
so her ultimate triumph this year isn't
gonna be slaying people it's gonna be
slang calculus the cool part is is that
Brainiac stiles gets to be her wingman
on that mission on the battlefield he
can't do
he's like a squishy cloth wearing mage
and she's like a plate wearing warrior
except he doesn't have any magic unless
you considered doing homework to be
magic the funny thing about that is is
that I feel like Malia feels like
homework is magic speaking of which
Lydia's crazy notes those were the same
symbols on the computer screen of the
mute which seemed like encoded
instructions from the benefactor I
didn't recognize any patterns in the
symbols but if you think you know what
they're all about just write it in the
comments number three the mute is
killing supernatural people so here's a
weird thought if he has no mouth how did
he speak to Sean at the beginning of the
episode when he was trapped in the
bathroom
or was that voice coming from the
benefactor and not from the mutes mouth
we're probably gonna have to wait to the
next episode to find that out just
because the only communication we saw
from the mute like direct communication
was to Scott when he made that you know
whisper motion he's pretty clearly
getting instructions from the benefactor
via that weird computer pipeline he
plugged into it's like some kind of
magical cyber gear like a combination of
Technology and magic that actually
reminded me of this really weird Marvel
what-if story from like a long time ago
it was this story where Tony Stark
became dr. strange and he inscribed all
these magical runes on his Iron Man suit
so that he could automate spells the way
he would automate machinery I don't
think we're gonna see anything like that
on Teen Wolf anytime soon but I am
interested to see how the benefactor is
using the internet to control the mute
he does seem like he has cognition and
freewill but he also seems like a
flesh-and-blood robot being controlled
with a magical remote but on to number
two Kirra joins the lacrosse team even
though lacrosse felt like the challenge
for her this week and the relationship
with Scott was the reward I felt like it
should have been the other way around
like she had to overcome Scott's der
penis and as a reward she'd get to join
the lacrosse team Scott is the real
challenge for her here I mean lacrosse
is just gonna be way too easy just look
at her twirl her lacrosse stick I could
look at a Jif of her doing that all day
long I cannot wait to see her decapitate
someone with that the whole parents
moving thing feels like a dead end
because she's not gonna leave the show
and her parents aren't gonna move and
leave her in town to move in with one of
the other characters but I am so much
more excited about lacrosse now that
she's part of it before that happened it
was basically a straight-up reboot of
what happened freshman year now that
Kyra's on the team I
feel like all the lowepro scenes are
gonna start being about her which is way
more fun than just watching Scott go
alpha on everyone that's basically what
the season 1 plot was about him using
werewolf powers on the field so finally
my number one WTF moment of course Scott
bites Liam full disclosure I actually
knew this was gonna happen a long time
ago the creator of the show Jeff Davis
was talking about Liam becoming Scott's
new beta all summer I just didn't know
how it was gonna happen like how he was
gonna give him the bite I actually
thought it was a really cool twist on
the creation of a new werewolf Scott
would have never done that willingly and
the best moment was actually his WTF
reaction after the mute left like oh my
god what did I just do there were
actually two big moments in the episode
where Scott's brain just went offline
and then had like this violent reboot
several moments later like the first
time when he unconsciously kissed Keira
on the way to class and then was just
like wait but and then obviously the
second time at the end of the episode
where he just had the WTF derp face I'd
like to call him derp Scott in this
episode but he was being a hero and I
love the idea of Scott having a beta
that's a brand new character so I
totally forgive him for being a space
cadet so if you've been watching Teen
Wolf for a couple seasons now here's the
big question for you how many times do
you think that Scott has at a moment
like that where he just completely
spaces and goes out to lunch mentally
and then just wakes up moments later
realizing what he's done and do you
think this is gonna be a really big
issue with him not being able to think
in the moment or do you think it's him
just acting on instinct and it's not a
big issue like it's not gonna become a
problem
I do think Scott has very good instincts
but I'm curious to see how his
relationship with Keira twists that
overall I gave the episode a B+ it was
my favorite episode of the season so far
it was so much fun I love the new Liam
character I feel like we won't get to
know him until he's part of the pack
though so there's still a lot that we
don't know about him they've really just
teased a trouble of history so I'm
interested to find out why he got kicked
out of his last school lacrosse Kira was
amazing and Malia with the markers I
feel like was a really good misdirect
for what's probably gonna become a
really big problem later this season
when she finds out the Peters her father
it's too bad this airs during the summer
because I'd love to see a Halloween
episode where the pack dresses up as the
Avengers you guys could totally pick who
gets to be who but Scott has to be
Captain America and Lydia has to be
Scarlet Witch everybody else is up for
grabs but maybe
Malea could be she-hulk or angela
whoever she is she's definitely ought to
be vicious I feel like there's this
weird pattern emerging with the
characters like they face challenges if
they defeat them they get a special
reward either in the form of acceptance
or in the form of a relationship like
with Keira and Scott like if Malia
defeats math she gets to be a real
person like she's Pinocchio trying to
become a normal human and Kira's just
trying to fit in so if she can kick ass
at lacrosse and defeat Scott's
reluctance she'll get that relationship
that she wants and everyone's acceptance
let me know what you think that lydian
Stiles rewards are like what will Lydia
get if she can master her abilities so
this week was kind of crazy with the
guardians of the galaxy stuff going on
on Monday but I'm gonna try and do an
extra Teen Wolf bonus video next Monday
I'm trying to do those bonus videos
about you know mythology topics inside
the Teen Wolf Universe so be sure to
subscribe to get that and feel free to
leave me suggestions but I'm also adding
a playlist link in the description too
just in case you want to watch more
Teemo videos right now click here to get
my episode 2 video and click here to get
my episode 1 video thanks so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you